the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are
but you do that for yourself that's
that's the hardest work
if you start to think about that really
why are you where you are
in your life the choices that you have
made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself
so whether you call it soul or spirit or
higher self intelligence there is
i know this there's a light inside each
of you
all of us
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe
nation top 10.99
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle which you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best oprah winfrey
and my take on her top 10 rules for
success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one have empathy
i know you all understand better than
most that real progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being honesty and
above all
empathy i have to say that the single
most
important lesson i learned in 25 years
talking
every single day to people was that
there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us i tell you we don't want to
be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview
is we want to be validated we want to be
understood
i've done over 35 000
interviews in my career and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to be and
inevitably in their own way
asks this question was that okay
i heard it from president bush i heard
it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from
victims and perpetrators of crimes i
even heard it from beyonce and all of
her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says
was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument
in every encounter every exchange i will
tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay did you hear me
do you see me did what i
say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people
you may disagree with
that you'll have the the
courage to look them in the eye and hear
their point of view
and help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people
this is imperative for you as an
individual
and for our success as a nation rule
number two
stop comparing yourself to others what
about something that you feel like
you've personally achieved or overcome
is there something that you
are especially proud of yourself for
yeah i'm
especially proud of myself for not uh
living in the world of comparisons you
know
uh years ago when i pulled out that
wagon of fat i was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what i
thought you're supposed to look like or
what
size you're supposed to be so i've now
reached the point where i'm really okay
exactly where i am and that's you know
it's taken me a lifetime practically to
figure that out
and being okay exactly where you are
because preparing is a danger it's so
hard because we are in the world of
insta comparison you know and so
the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are
but you do that for yourself that's
that's the hardest work
rule number three learn to say no you
um are now the ceo of your company
you're the owner
and the ceo and you've got thousands of
people working for you yeah and as a ceo
do you have to say no to people all the
time and is that hard to do
uh you get other people who say no that
no okay um
saying no is hard that is one of the big
big
lessons life lessons for me i i i grew
up obviously
girl uh raised in the south woman need
to please wanting to please everybody
so it took me a long time to get that
lesson of only saying yes to what you
intend to say yes to and
and so uh i tried to do all of my
business decisions and personal
decisions
based upon my intention rule number four
believe many of you as i have been
as i am are where you are in your life
based upon what you believe and it's not
just what you think
you believe on the surface it's also
your shadow beliefs
that are holding you back from moving
into
the life that you believe you deserve
what i know is if you're not looking at
the shadows if you're not looking
at what is subconsciously running
through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough which is
a tape that's playing for a lot of
people
if you're not conscious of that then you
end up
acting out of that belief system and not
out of what
you know to be the truest or want to be
the truest
for yourself you don't become what you
want because so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story
is so powerful because he started to act
as though he already had it
he would go up to mulholland drive he
would drive away saying
thinking i already have those things i
just haven't accessed them as yet
i believe those things are going to come
to me and i'm going to act like they are
so i'm going to move forward in my life
in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with
what i say i believe so if you start to
think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life
the choices that you have made have been
because of what you believe to be true
for yourself
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick and i want you to get the habit
of self-confidence and self-belief the
link to join absolutely for free
is in the description below figure out
where your power base is your number one
job is to become more of yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself
become so skilled so vigilant
so flat out fantastic
at what you do that your talent cannot
be dismissed rule number five live your
life with intention
the biggest transformation for me was
living my life with intention
you know what i know i live by this law
of that's the third law of motion
physics which you put out is coming back
but before you even put it out you have
an intention and so to have
a clarity of intention about what you
actually want to do
and why you want to do it is the most
important thing and then to just
set that vision and have every step you
make move you in the direction of that
vision it doesn't mean that every day
it's going to happen
some days you're off track like i
intended to work out 45 minutes i only
got in
37 this morning well that's better than
two it's better than zero
and that's that's that's that's what i
said okay at least you got some movement
in and
i'll go back and i'll make up the other
eight later but
i think you just made it up actually as
i was walking i think i think this is
gonna be eight minutes i'm gonna make it
up
so uh it's it's about it's daily renewal
it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right
because that's what every sunrise means
it's oh gosh it's another chance to get
it right
rule number six be yourself there has to
be
some way that this darkness
can be banished with light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary friday
in december
so whether you call it soul or spirit or
higher self intelligence there
is i know this there's a light inside
each of you all of us
that illuminates your very human
beingness
if you let it and as a young girl from
rural mississippi
i learned long ago that being myself was
much easier than pretending to be
barbara walters although when i first
started because i had barbara in my head
i would try to sit like barbara talk
like bob removed like barbara and then
one night i was on the news
reading the news and i called canada
kanada
and that was the end of me being barbara
i cracked myself
up on tv couldn't stop laughing and my
real personality came through and i
figured out
oh gee i can be a much better oprah than
i could be a pretend
barbara rule number seven help others i
have a very
big life and so people with big lives
can do big things and so i started to
think about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life
i grew up poor uh on welfare with my
mother for part of my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years old
and
my mother had said we're not going to
have christmas
because we can't afford it and my
feeling at the time was okay well
so that one's that's santa claus bit
he's 12 that's when i realized there was
no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh i remember feeling like
it's gonna be really hard on christmas
morning
to go outside everybody had you know you
go outside with your toys
what am i going to do when everybody
else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class
and say i got nothing so that's what i
was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up some three
nuns came to our house
and they gave me a doll and they bought
us food and we had our christmas that
was the best christmas of my life
because somebody remembered and i wasn't
going to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling for children who had nothing
so i decided to go to south africa
originally i wanted to do a million kids
because i thought we can do a million
kids
and then just realize with i only had uh
four weeks vacation so in four weeks i
could not reach a million kids because i
didn't want to just write a check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face and say to that
child
somebody remembered you and so that's
what i did
with my life this christmas i took 41
people from here
hired another 50 people over there and
we were traveling
caravan from one village to the next we
did 2 000 kids a day
we had um parties for children
who were orphans and it was
singularly i will tell you i could weep
thinking about it
the singularly the best experience of
my life the singularly
best experience of my life the first day
in africa
where we had um three
280 kids in a room and every single one
of those kids had lost a parent
every single one of those children they
were aged three
to 17 in that room and my team
that you're talking about i have the
greatest team in the world my team
in the here in the united states had
been in contact with the orphanages so
that by the time we got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had um uh
this summer every black doll
manufacturer in the country had sent me
dolls because i
these girls had never seen black dolls
and so it was my mission
to do for them what the nuns had done
for me was to let the
african girl see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have
soccer balls we bought radios we bought
clothes
and the most important thing is we had
their names on every box
for every child and i called up the
children one by one
and when those children you know
received their gifts and then waited for
the next child to receive their gifts
and said i said nobody can open their
presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three
and those children open their presents
was the single
greatest moment of my life and i share
that with you
i share that with you because that's
what i can do i can be i
have a big life so i can take 50 000
presents and do that over and over and
over again to orphanage
effort orphanage but what i felt in that
room for those from those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces of those women
when you look into the eyes of someone
and you
give them a gift whether that be a
physical gift or it'd be
a gift from your spiritual self
from your presence from the essence of
you and you see the light you see the
joy
what i felt in that room was not just
that i was remembered
that that the child felt that i was
remembered but you felt a sense of
hope a sense of validation
a sense of validation that somebody
cared about
me and i will tell you that of
all the years and shows that i have done
and every theme for every show that i've
done
the single common denominator
denominator that i found that
every human being is looking for is
validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter that they
matter
and what happened in that room that was
the greatest day of my life
i knew that those children knew in that
moment
that they mattered that they mattered
and so i
encourage you it's exciting to be able
to write a check
it's even more exciting to be able to
touch
one life to be able to do that for
one person it's like cynthia was saying
when you can do that for one
person when you can do that you will
know that your life has meaning
and i will tell you when i left that
place my friend gail and i were there
and we're all boohoo and we're like
booming with the children oh my god
and gail was saying what is it what is
it we're so full as gail said to me she
said you know as big as your show
is as big as your show is what happened
in that room
seemed bigger what happened in that room
sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life and a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is not like
you
somebody who is like you who is indeed
if you are feeling depressed or you are
feeling down or you're feeling like
things aren't going the way you want
them to go in your life
the way you turn that around is to reach
outside of yourself
to somebody else reach outside of
yourself to somebody else
it will change you
it will change you rule number eight
know
your purpose i don't make resolutions
anymore i have a word so at my
dinner table we all go around the table
and we say
what's your word for this year okay and
my word
is purpose my word for this year is
purpose because
when i look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in a
year because your life's so full
yeah so another now i just go back and i
look through my phone so i was doing
that
on new year's eve looking through the
phone at all the pictures all the stuff
you've done
and i did a lot of things but i didn't
do a lot of things on purpose
with intentional purpose so my thing
this year is don't do anything unless
you have an intention
and a purpose behind it rule number nine
find good friends
you wish yourself they call her auntie
gayle and me mamo
i said you all wish to have a friend
like auntie gayle
you want to have a friend who wants
the most the best and the highest for
you
i have never seen a person like gail
i've never
yeah you know everybody especially if
you
uh are on the rise in your career and
you have had certain friends
and they all act like they're happy for
you but not everybody's happy for you
and every now and then you can hear just
a teen nazi bit of jealousy you can hear
it you can sense it
i've never had a moment's jealousy from
gail
in you know the 30 odd years of her
friendship except
for the one time i was on stage dancing
with tina turner
that's the only time i ever heard gail
goes i wish that was me
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is listen to your life's whispers in all
of the years of doing the oprah show
there were many days that i sat in my
chair across from
one or two or five or six or seven
people and i would be
so frustrated because
i just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say why didn't you pay attention
to your life i said on the show probably
the producers tell me that they counted
33 times but i know i thought it
at least a thousand times i would say
listening to your life
as it whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head
with a brick or come crashing down on
you
as a brick wall is one of the greatest
principles of life because there are
many things that happen
in life that are beyond our control
natural disasters death
unexplained events but there are also
many many many things in life which we
can control
and become out of control because you're
just
not paying attention you are
sleepwalking through your life
and i have seen this so many times on
the show
i wanted to take the guests and go would
you just pay
attention so this is what i've learned
and how
i've explained it to myself
life whispers to you all the time
your life is speaking to you all around
from the time you wake up in the morning
and every single experience that's
coming into
your personal space into
your physical space all of those
experiences
are speaking to you they're telling you
something about your life and about
your circumstances it whispers and if
you don't get the whisper
the whisper gets louder if you don't get
the whisper when it gets louder
it gets i call it like a little pebble
like a little thump upside your head
when i was a kid if i was doing
something my grandmother didn't like
she'd just turn around and thump me she
wouldn't even look at me she'd just give
me a thump and
i know that's that's my cue to stop
it or you we're gonna get worse
the whisper is the message the pebble or
the thump upside the head
usually it's gone into a problem you
don't pay attention
to the problem the problem becomes a
brick upside your head
the brick upside your head is a crisis
you don't pay attention to the brick
upside your head
the crisis turns into a disaster and the
whole
house brick wall comes falling down now
i've got a very special bonus clip that
i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create
a plan of action you have a over 90
chance of following through and when you
share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you the
angel network i've been on the air for
a long time but it was the angel network
that actually focused my internal gps
it helped me to decide that i wasn't
just gonna be on tv every day
but that the goal of my shows my
interviews my business my
philanthropy all of it whatever ventures
i might pursue
would be to make clear that
what unites us
is ultimately far more redeeming
and compelling than anything that
separates me
because what it become clear to me and i
want you to know it isn't always clear
in the beginning because as i said
i've been on television since i was 19
years old
but around 94 i got really clear so
don't expect the clarity to come all at
once to know your purpose right away
but what became clear to me was that i
was here on earth to use television and
not be used by it
to use television to illuminate the
transcendent
power of our better angels
so this angel network it didn't just
change the lives of those who were
helped but the lives
of those who also did the helping
it reminded us that no matter who we are
or what we look
like or what we may believe it is
both possible and more importantly
it becomes powerful to come together
in common purpose and common effort
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there